un frate come stai mi chiedo a te non ci
sentiamo da quant'è che non accendo la
ulteriori informazioni su tre consulte
alla pagina web di apple si cela sorella
non ci sentiamo da un botto di tempo
senti ho scaricato mario run melo a via
grazie
[Musica]
ecco cosa ho trovato cercando ciao
sorella non ci sentiamo da un bar
va bene allora ragazzi uscita la nuova
app sull'app store che solo per gli
utenti apple perché quelli android
puzzano di merda come me e infatti ho
dovuto giocarlo sull'ipad perché non
potevo giocarlo sul telefono a via mario
run siri ecco cosa ho trovato su
internet
vedo che comunque nintendo ha fatto bene
ad appoggiarsi soltanto ad apple perché
la us è un sistema che funziona
egregiamente allora mario run maiorano
dovrebbe essere un range game quindi
tipo su carmelo e ha così si badi e
mario cioè caro inglese va beh caro
mario perché non ti unisci al party che
abbiamo organizzato nel castello e non
immagino sapere che cosa fate in quei
party cuciniamo una torta ecco infatti
la tua adorata facce va bene x force che
mela dei come al solito se bowser che
deve far passare la minchia la via fin
qua la tua fucka prenderò quella torta e
anche pcie guarda del piccione frega un
cazzo però la torta magari sembra lasci
contro supermario erano in this game
mario maniera automatica lì ma io che
faccio la figura dei pali e allora che
cazzo faccio io fa tutto lui non sta
facendo niente bello e comodo sto gioco
non troppo comodo se fai uno sbaglio
vieni risucchiato in una bolla e prova
di nuovo ho capito
posso saltare mario salt e
automaticamente anche tutti i nemici
[Musica]
mica gioco più difficile degli ultimi
anni ragazzi io totti lo schermo è più
lo in alto sata o hara fra non serve a
un cazzo cazzo salto a fare aprendo le
monete vabbè saltando sui nemici fai
delle mosse [ __ ] bello presenza fa
tutto lui ma che cazzo di gioco è lega a
quella il castello che c'e la sabbia nel
culo fantastico
secondo me comunque hanno tentato di
cucinare la torta ma il forno esploso
perché non sono capaci però variare
anche asta anche scaricando i dati fanta
questa credo sia la schermata per ora
più difficile di tutto il gioco per
adesso walking underground ma ragazzi
avere da me non sembra che tipo mario
sia più un anno del solito non so perché
sono al rientro monete widmann e youtube
e venduto mario venduto grazie dove
cazzo sta andando come il castello non è
di qualunque perfetto a volte mi prendo
male perché perché credo di morire però
mi ricordo che in questo gioco non si
può morire perfetto grande nintendo per
questo tocca tu stai andando a ciò solo
due bolle ok ho capito quindi posso
morire in teoria solo due volte poi poi
ciò nel culo quindi questa versione
tranquilla di mario rane perché se
faranno cat mario run sarà un po più un
problema
lo vedete che tipo normale mario e nano
che cazzo è l'anno schiacciato con una
pressa best è stato difficile finalmente
i mondi dall 1 al 4 devono essere
comprati per potreste giocare compra
spilla sborsa investi brava nintendo
brava in quanto costa la rivista roba
per farmelo capire a chiunque faccia un
cazzo eccola la parte che fa incazzare
nel gioco mi mag non avevo capito mi
stavo giusto chiedendo quando questo
range game sarebbe diventato un reggae
per 10 euro con gli opc che viene al
limon armi in casa
ok ragazzi adesso abbiamo tagliato
questa parte di video perché avevo
comprato gli altri livelli di supermario
adesso vedrete che cosa è successo nel
mentre che tentavo di comprare i livelli
di supermario in gioia allora io voglio
dire una roba ho provato a prendere che
cosa da 10 euro e mi hanno bloccato la
carta ma perché perché probabilmente
mario run tipo sede in uganda e quindi
tipo hanno visto che sta arrivando un
pagamento in uganda ma bloccata la carta
porca [ __ ] uno vuole spendere i soldi e
non può spendere i soldi prendi questi
10 euro senza bloccarmi cotte in banca
ma bloccato la carta ve lo giuro che lei
gigèn del cazzo
niente chiama la mia zia che lavora in
banca farmi sbloccare la carta fantab
più bello è un gioco interattivo chiama
anche i tuoi parenti ad aiutarti a
giocare porca [ __ ]
[Musica]
era pronto madrina la madrina con stai
aprirete stavo giocando una roba noe
praticamente ho fatto per comprare un
videogioco so che probabilmente non lo
so non ho capito che vorranno ha
bloccato la carta ok grazie facciamo
bene le cose che non puoi fare perché
devi spendere i soldi che non puoi
spendere soldi bloccano il conto
corrente bene prossima volta faranno
market maiorani in realtà è un
aggiornamento che fa ancora più
incazzare perché catemario alla versione
più brutta di mario e se provi a giocare
ti chiacchierano il canale di youtube
per gli altri riusciamo a fare 3 20
secondi 20 secondi grazie dio se ne vale
la pena
sì bello fantastico ma se riesco a
finirlo in 20 secondi cosa che non credo
possibile 4316 povero non puoi giocare a
questi giochi per ricchi pensate se c'è
la scritta di bonarda bloccato il conto
in banca
welcome to tò del rally sono 8 ha detto
non me ne frega un cazzo fammi giocare
torta in action due non me ne frega
niente fammi giocare a qualcosa non c'è
niente per questo video
oddio
cos'è a devi prendere deve arrivare alla
stella grazie a una stella coinres audio
figata madonna madonna i soldi i soldi
la carta il blocco in banca non sono più
un cazzo perfetto presa
l'ultima l'ho presa grazie brutto
[ __ ] ho vinto
non solo anche di una capito che quello
era lo scopo di a devo fare più punti
possibile ho vinto ho vinto io c'ho più
soldi di te va bene ragazzi lasciamo
perdere con sta cosa di mario ranno
tanto abbiamo capito che mi hanno
bloccato tutto fantastico
ciao siri come stai meravigliosamente io
no ho trovato una serie di negozi di
giocattoli che non dista molto dentro
cui ti trovi che sarà veramente
fighissimo potrà andare un negozio di
giocattoli secolo il problema che non
posso pagare un cazzo paga la carta non
ho più non ho trovato negozi di
giocattoli che corrispondono la tua
richiesta ci sono due coccodrilli poi
risultati di diversi campionati
cosa vuoi vedere basket calcio football
americano ok ok su spiaggia ok mattina
tanto ma cosa fanno al campionato di
hockey su spiaggia siri raccontami una
favola curioso con una favola russe se
vuoi
c'era una volta che io pensavo che la
giornata non potesse andare più di merda
di quanto non lo fosse già mi canti una
canzone ti risparmia la scena ma vabbè
guarda non puoi essere peggio di mcrae
che te lo giuro mi dispiace
dai dai una canzone sora si e limitanti
sto chiedendo di cantare chissà cosa
questa è la conosci we are the robot ta
ta ta ta we are the robot da qatar dei
robot si va dai ragazzi questo era un
video su mario rane si è trasformato in
un anno sensata su siri perché mario
rami ha bloccato la carta su internet
quindi direi di concludere qua è stato
bello però mario ram per quanto l'ho
giocato per quei due minuti è stato
molto divertente
niente ragazzi spero di video sia
piaciuto che concludono episodio e cose
da ragazzi di aver preso un momento è un
mi piace ai capace di facebook è quindi
dotata la vestizione sono divertiti
siete lì ci rivediamo forse un video
fatemi sapere se volete che continui
semi sblocca la carta così magari blocco
di nuovo da ragazzi